the 2pm panel of the afternoon on
integrate and analyze my name is Kathy
McEwen and I'll be moderating the panel
I'm a professor in the computer science
department here at Columbia University
and I'm also the inaugural director of
the Columbia's new Institute for data
sciences in engineering so we're going
to start our panel with Susan MacGregor
who is an assistant professor in
journalism at Columbia University and
she comes here from her work with the
wall street journal where she did a lot
of work on on programming of graphics so
with that I'll turn it over to Susan
it's really great to be here I
I've had a little bit of opportunity to
to work in the last year and a half with
the center for digital research and
scholarship here at Columbia and sort of
talk about some of the issues that we
encounter with data in journalism and
it's kind of an interesting space for
journalists because even though what we
call in the field computer-assisted
reporting has actually been around for
decades it's always for the most part
been a very niche practice but I am part
of a now swelling number of ranks of
folks in the industry who use data and
visualization and analysis on a regular
basis to produce journalism and also to
publish publish our work so I just sort
of wanted to talk about what sort of my
background interest in this comes from
the fact that having worked in a
newsroom in part because this came from
such a small community within the
industry we don't really have a lot of
really well developed practices around
data management and some of our best
efforts we found we're very short coming
and it's interesting because I think
that unlike a lot in a way we're coming
at this from the opposite direction that
a lot of people in universities are
right which is that as journalists were
generally not the subject matter experts
we're not the people with the data or
their people who want to sort of be able
to access and interpret the data and so
for us the sort of integrating and
analyze is really is a fun is an
essential part of it in a way it's
almost the way that we discover the data
that we use to do our work because
access to the data set while it can be
difficult is only the first part of
making it useful for what we do and the
necessity to integrate that with the
expertise of researchers in the field is
what actually lets us draw value from it
so this is an example of coverage from
the guardian UK during the 2011 riots
there I'm not sure how familiar folks
are with this you probably heard that
you know you probably heard about this
story what I think was really unique
about the the use of data and this comes
from the data blog at the Guardian which
is perhaps best known for its work in
the wikileaks case just prior to this
was that the work that
the guardian did and why this was so the
sort of integrate and analyze part of
this was that they used a combination of
data sources in order to sort of
discover and tell the story of the UK
riots so what you're seeing right here
is a sort of a variation on a map and i
won't i won't risk trying to go to the
live version but what you're seeing is
is sort of the the integration of
multiple data sets so what the Guardian
did was a combination of use using user
reports one of the biggest parts of this
story when it broke was just trying to
find out where the riots were happening
it was really it really caused a quite a
panic in the UK actually the way that
these riots spread around the country
and and therefore the very early hours
of this story the real question was just
where are these things happening and so
the Guardian essentially put out a call
a lot of their use you know a lot of
their readers users who use social media
called in reports texted used social
media to send in reports about where
riots were happening and they produced
in the end a very very simple map almost
rudimentary Matt that just showed where
the riots were taking place and that was
extremely effective it was actually this
very basic math was the number one
trafficked page on their site for two
days running which for the Guardian
which is a leader in in online traffic
was a really big deal but what you're
looking at here is actually the
integration of that data set with two
other data sets one is the location is
the location the the home addresses of
suspects who were arrested for riot
related offences in the in the days
following the start of the riots and
this was an essential part because of
course after something like this happens
you want to know not just where it's
happening but who is doing it and of
course why and the Guardians analysis
was instrumental in this because what
they did was after gathering court
records they actually had to get an
order from the Ministry of Justice to
allow for the wholesale release of
arrest records from around the UK they
went through encoded each of them this
is probably the closest to what the
researchers in the room are familiar
with right they went they went through
and they coded each arrest record to
determine whether or not based on
location
offense and and time whether it was a
riot related offense and then they
overlaid that with with demographic data
this is called the deprivation index in
the UK which is basically a measure of
poverty and this was all inspired by the
fact that David Cameron had made a
public statement that the riots had
nothing to do with poverty and it seems
remarkable which is exactly what the
editor thought and which is why this
analysis was performed it also produced
some of them one of some of the larger
insights of the story which was the
so-called understood as a so-called riot
commute which in understanding what was
happening was looking at where people
were rioting and actually even before
this part of the story was told was was
contrasting where arrest where arrested
suspects lived versus where they had
rioted and and this became interpreted
as the riot commute and what was
discovered was that it was actually a
very organized effort it wasn't people
sort of running into the streets enraged
they were leaving their homes they were
getting on the nearest train they were
traveling to city centres and then they
were rioting in particular locations and
at particular times which gave a very
different flavor to the understanding of
what was going on so this is an example
from from our field of where of how
integrating and analyzing data is
important and I guess you know the thing
for us is that we are always cross
referencing across lots of different
types of data lots of different areas of
expertise and sometimes we're doing this
based on a background you know this is
this is sort of the reporters intuition
which really tends to be sort of
collected implicit knowledge is what I
would characterize it out it's a subject
matter expertise that we accrue but we
don't always document in the same way
this is a second piece from that same
coverage package and this came from was
inspired by another statement of david
cameron's which was that social media
like Facebook and Twitter had been used
to organize these riots and therefore
needed the UK government needed a
so-called red button to be able to shut
down these services in the case of
public emergency and this is a pretty
significant issue particularly in the UK
which doesn't have the same
kind of press protections as we have in
the US and so this could have of course
been a pretty significant threat to
communication and press Liberty there it
already social media already produce you
some sort of weird conflicts and what's
allowed to be reported about but again
what we see here is this is based on the
user reports of win particular events
when writing began to happen in
particular places and this is data that
they obtained from Twitter they asked
they reached out to Twitter and said hey
can we have all the tweets that are
tagged with this this particular hashtag
and and then they looked at the traffic
on those tweets what you see here
actually which is the largest spike that
black line is actually the hashtag riot
cleanup which saw the greatest and most
sustained volume of traffic on social
media of course later in part I think
because of this because of the doubt
that this cast the issue was explored
further and it was found of course that
the protesters mostly had been
organizing through blackberry messenger
right um and what's interesting which is
which is not public because guess what
they know that everybody can see that
stuff so this is another example and I
think what's important here and in sort
of how it ties into the research
community as well is that um you know
this is obviously not a statistical
analysis right and of course I'm sure
mark will have things to share on that
but but one of the things that they did
one of the things that they did and this
is this is how journalism both benefits
from you know sort of more more academic
research practices but of course serves
a different function which is that the
function of this graph was to call into
question the story being offered the
story line being offered by the
government in point of fact actually the
Guardian did collaborate with
researchers at the University of
Manchester and LSD later that year who
did do this detestable analysis and
confirmed that in fact there was no
correlation between social media traffic
on Facebook and Twitter and the activity
of the riots so this is another example
where again we sort of take we take data
and we have to integrate it I had the
opportunity to some this is a medic
Medicare fraud cases the graphic from a
series of Medicare fraud stories that
were report
by a former colleague of mine from The
Wall Street Journal Maurice Hammond who
is one of the leaders in computer
assisted reporting and I had the
opportunity to interview him about the
kind of work that he does in this case
and while it does rely on large volumes
of data again it's important to
recognize that we don't have the
expertise around this data and very
often things like what the column names
mean in your table are extremely opaque
to us or for example with medical
records as I'm sure many everyone here
is familiar right are very opaque Lee
coded as to what actually the entries
mean and so when I asked him about his
process on this in addition to
successfully obtaining the data which
was several billion records still only
about five percent of the Medicare
records for that year he the filings
many of which were redundant and there
were all kinds of all kinds of issues
with them was it he was working with he
basically had some expert contacts at
Dartmouth University and he would work
with them and just say what what should
I be looking for what's unusual what
what are these things and basically
through that and sort of applying you
know typical you know search and
analysis methods was able to identify
the the folks that you see here the the
the outlier in the very top right corner
is a particular doctor here in New York
who is performing very unusual
procedures for their particulars I
believe it's either a pediatrician or a
GP who is performing extremely
sophisticated tests and all of the other
bubbles are the gray ones are actually
people who had been reviewed for
misconduct and sort of this this led
this has led to prosecution and to
review of the methods by many of the
people who were involved in it so a
really important part of this was was
engaging the subject matter expert to
decode this information this is another
this is another example this is actually
not by a traditional journalist this is
by a data scientist at something called
social flow and in this case they he
basically the the kony 2012 phenomenon
that some of you may have may have heard
about on social media he kind of reverse
engineered what had happened
and how this viral this this thing went
viral and the important thing about it
or the really interesting thing about it
is that especially in the online world
there spent a lot of thinking recently
that you know the all of these these
things go viral you know just online
it's all digital and essentially his
analysis of who was who was tweeting
when and looking at information about
their geography where they were as well
as as information from their profile
which identified them as people who were
part of religious youth movements
actually what they what he was able to
deduce was essentially that the people
who sort of tipped the scales on this
online viral his online viral phenomenon
were were actually part of a large
in-person ground network that had been
connected with the organization that was
promoting this event for a long long
time so it kind of gave lie to the idea
that this is just the kind of thing that
explodes spontaneously which might be
obvious to some who are kind of familiar
with these systems but but win against
the common understanding at the time so
that's all I wanted to share is sort of
how we use these practices and to say
that you know one of the things that
that I personally and many of my
colleagues are interested in is you know
we like everyone in journ in journalism
like in many other industries we are you
know facing a reduction in resources and
one of the things is that we're still
somewhat permeating mentality in the
industry of the idea of yesterday's news
and so developing practices that are
efficient for us to gather metadata
produce things that are reproducible I
know is a topic earlier today and be
able to leverage that forward so that
the the knowledge similar to researchers
in the room that is cultivated by these
reporters isn't isn't lost when they
leave an organization or finish a story
but can actually be used by by other
journalists in much the same way that
that the academic discussion is
happening here is extremely important to
us so looking forward to sort of hearing
what everyone has to say and how we can
improve these processes our second
panelist is going to be coming to us
from
guy I hope you can pull that up her name
is Heather Pia wash ease co-founder of
impact story and this is a web
application that helps scholars tell how
their research has had impact and she'll
be talking about the different metrics
that she uses thanks so much for skyping
me and I am really sad to not be there
you are my people and I wish I were
there the reason I'm not is because i'm
busy coding impact story to make it even
better come new improvements coming soon
to you but what i'm going to be doing in
this talk is putting analyzing data in
the context of impact and specifically
analyzing data about our data so i will
be talking about research data i won't
be talking about slicing and dicing that
research data but instead slicing and
dicing the impact about the research
data so consider it a segue to the next
section what i was invited to talk about
and so i hope that that it will stir
some great conversation so what we want
to do is understand the impact of our
datasets and something that we and i'll
include myself in this that we as data
data loving people data set loving
people often forget is that impact is
not just citations citations are a bit
of a holy grail we don't have them
working well yet we desperately want
them but they're not the whole story and
we will lose out big time if we think
they're the whole story it's important
that we take a step back and think about
all the data we need to analyze about
impact specifically there are many types
of engagements so there are views people
look at our data there are saves people
bookmark our data for looking at it
later there are discussions people talk
about data not explicitly in here is the
fact they're analyzing data actually and
potentially talking about it with their
lab groups or online there are formal
references when people refer to data
informal publications and then people
can recommend datasets again formally or
informally these are all different types
of engagement they're all so different
people who do these engagements so one
is researchers and now there is teachers
students policymakers practitioners when
we think about just journal citations
two data sets as you can imagine we miss
a lot of both of these pictures so
journal article citations specifically
is a formal reference from a scholar a
journal citation in text link or for
example mentioning an accession number
in a method section that's a formal
reference from a scholar to write it's
not using the established mechanisms we
have for doing that in the citation list
and so it misses out on a lot of the
tools and a lot of the social norms that
go along with the reference list but it
is it is still a formal reference from a
scholar a blog of an in text link one
characterized as an informal discussion
potentially from a scholar if it's a
scholars blog a tweet of a data set link
or a data set ID is an informal
discussion from a scholar if that's
color if the tweeter is a scholar it may
also be an indication that a teacher a
student a policymaker a journalist right
others are interested in our data sets
mendeley are delicious or different ways
to bookmark to save data sets for future
reference and those we there are some
metrics that talk about who and for what
reason but there's lots that's not known
there yet when data is put on github for
example or when software is put on
github they have a mechanism for a star
and other data repositories can have
that too which can mean a recommendation
by someone all of these different things
are ways of following the following the
engagement of a community or communities
with our data sets in a very broad sense
and as those engagements move online we
can begin to track them now sometimes
some types of tracking or creepy and
aren't appropriate but some types of
tracking are very appropriate and things
that we should be building I heard
and things that we should be building
into our tool and into our platforms and
this is in fact the social norm in
social media today so Twitter we just
heard at Twitter and and mendeley and
others have api's that expose
engagements at appropriate at an
appropriate level of granularity and an
accepted level of granularity so as our
engagements move online we can track
them and then we can analyze data about
our data and from this we can inform our
policies in sent people to share their
data learn to build our tools all the
things that I think people will be
talking about earlier today and we'll
talk about later again this this all
when we think about all the different
types of engagement and all the
different types of engages it lets us
move from a metric of is the data
available or not yes or no past the
metric of has the data being used as
measured by citations which is good but
still just one dimensional that doesn't
capture everything and it makes a
one-dimensional set of winners and
losers to a real palette which I like to
think of as a flavor palate um and which
I like to think of in terms of ice cream
because ice cream is delicious so um so
people could argue that there's one best
kind of ice cream say chocolate and many
people would agree with them but that
really depends on your use most people
do not put chocolate ice cream on there
apple pie right and yet most people love
having apple pie with ice cream probably
with vanilla and so we need some vanilla
ice cream to exist as well lots of
people have champagne ice cream there's
just lots of kinds of ice cream we want
them all to exist which means we need
different spectra different dimensions
on which to measure them and value them
for example there could be data sets
that are useful as a standalone
reanalysis to build another hypothesis
and test another hypothesis that's one
type of use and should be recognized and
valued
for what it is it's possible there's
another type of data set that's not used
in formal publications but it's a great
teaching data set and teachers all over
have it on their syllabi and students
learn all sorts of things about it and
it's never cited right we really want to
be able to identify that kind of impact
and recognize it for what it is there
could be other data sets that don't make
much what many waves in the scholarly
literature but you know what they do a
great job of informing a guardian piece
which which which makes a big difference
in public perception where's there's
many types of data sets it's important
that we analyze the data about our data
to be able to get these nuances and I'll
mention because I often i often don't
because it's still in the future but um
all of these things that i've talked
about are largely in terms of
quantitative numbers but obviously what
we really want to get to is qualitative
information and real world changing
impact that still beyond most of what we
can do but that's that's obviously the
goal to measure impact flavor even more
deeply than than is simple today so how
can we do all of this what is possible
now what data exists and how can we
analyze it I'm going to go through these
briefly and then hopefully we can have
good questions at the end after all the
sessions so I'm going to be talking
about this in the context of impact
story which is a nonprofit web
application that I've co-founded with
Jason preme with the goal what and I
have done that because as many of you
know my research passion is in
understanding patterns of data sharing
and reuse and understanding those
patterns to help inform policies and to
help create incentives for effective and
efficient data sharing and the tools
just didn't exist to do that right and I
got impatient and tired of waiting and
started to build the world that we want
to see and so so the application exists
right now at impact story org it's
founded by the sloan Foundation and it
currently tracks impacts for all sorts
of metrics including datasets encourage
you to check it out
um here's a picture of what impact story
does is a is for a scholar it collects
all their diverse sorts of research
products and shows diverse metrics about
them so articles but also data sets so
here are my data set for articles that
I've published you can see on the right
hand side there's an indication that
they've been viewed um if you click on
them you can drill in and see those
views we're characterizing dryad
downloads as views by the scholars I'll
take into this on another slide in more
detail but so impact story collects all
these different impacts and shows them
in context and makes the data openly
available um I want to be quick to
mention that it's only one tool that
exists now to do this altmetric com has
a bookmarklet and an and a tool that
will track data sets that have do is
excuse me plumb analytics um tracks
various kinds of diverse products
including data sets and the data
citation index currently tracks
citations for aggregate citations from
data repositories that have identified
them them themselves I believe is the
current status of that and so go check
those out my examples will be from
impact story but these are these are
other products that do often similar
things okay so number one what do we
need to do to bring about a world where
we can do a better job of analyzing the
data about our data the first thing is
we need more data we need more data
about our data to be available we and
what that means one thing is more
metrics to be exposed so dryad and fig
share and others lots of institutional
data repositories display the number of
times that data sets have been viewed
and downloaded which is fantastic and
facilitates a lot of this work it's even
better when it's available via an API
but we can talk about that more later
icpsr and or NL DAC and others take it a
step further and go and hunt down
citations and make those
available as data about the data icpsr
does is really a leader in in data about
I data they furthermore break down how
many downloads are from datasets versus
documentation then they take it a step
further and say when people have been
logged in and downloaded what have they
said is there a role in their
institution are they faculty grad
students undergrads or others and that
this when you break it down like this
and when you break it down by
institution you can really start to get
some of that impact flavor bubbling up
to the top and this is done obviously in
a way that does respect privacy and
doesn't do things that people don't
expect which is the balancing job when
mining logs so there's best practice
ways to do this here are some examples
they're still pretty rare on the ground
doing more of this will help us
understand impact better secondly more
support for all types of engagement so
right now um when metrics exist they
largely exist to show downloads and to
show views but that certainly isn't all
of the research lifecycle um there are
not very many tools that exist right now
to let someone bookmark a data set for
later reference you can put them in
delicious or a site you like or mendeley
but the support there isn't great yet we
really need to advocate for good support
often maybe those tools can come in our
data repositories I don't know but it's
an underserved area right now I'm
similarly ways to recommend datasets are
pretty weak this is there's a full
palette of this for articles I guess is
what I'm trying to say but the the tools
to support this kind of web native
engagement for data are still really
weak and so hence there's not much data
there for us to look at for it to track
impact on the third in this point is
that we need more derived metrics with
more context so understanding that um
data set on dry it has 1906 package
views sounds kind of like a lot but who
knows
that actually a lot really nobody knows
so when we show it on impact story for
example we give that wrong number and
importantly you can click on that wrong
number to drill into the Dryad page and
see see more information but we also
give a percentile so that 97 100 at the
top line right there near that little
blue bar that's the percentile that that
views is compared to other data sets
deposited that same year in dryad the
255 total downloads is between the 89th
and the 97th percentile of all datasets
deposited and dry add that year this
kind of giving context to our numbers is
really important and and requires data
to do that the fact that it's our range
is because there's ties and it also
includes ninety-five percent house man
if you're for centos um yeah so this is
another example of how these badges are
tied to context we need our data about
data to be more open so that we can mash
it up right we can't you can do all the
analysis you want if you can get the
data and if you can show your analysis
again then it's useful this means open
text mining of articles because that's
for a lot of the impact information is
not all of it but a whole lot and a lot
of important stuff that people currently
care about we need open data from
repositories so these download counts
and understanding how the download
counts were derived and understanding
metadata about the download yes about
divisions of the download count things
like that and finally and crucially we
also need open metrics from our
aggregators so the the current world
that we have with articles are the
scopus and web of science and Google
Scholar their citation metrics are not
open data which severely limits how
people can build tools on top of that we
want a different world for data sets and
so these aggregators are really ought to
have open data for us to make full use
of learning how to understand an impact
from them however you have about two
minutes left perfect because
I'm on point number three so point
number one was more data for our data
point number two is that it should be
more open and point number three is that
we need to raise awareness the that ways
to track data exists and that those ways
can get better so so continuing to raise
awareness that people can put their data
sets on their CV furthermore they can
put them there with some context about
how much has happened with them recently
and this is really encouraged for
example by the NSF policy I'm sure
you've mentioned today already to
support listing data sets I encouraging
people to list their um the metrics that
show that those data sets have had an
impact will drive demand for more of
this and will drive change which is what
we need to see if we are to get to a
world with long lineups for ice cream
where where we have good information
about what kind of ice cream is in the
most demand and the most loved thanks
very much
so our final panelist is mark Hanson
mark is the respondent for the panel so
we'll see how he responds to what others
have said mark is a director of the
brown Institute for media in innovation
he's also chair of the new media center
in the institute for data science and
engineering and he's a professor of
journalism at Columbia University thank
you very much for the opportunity to
speak with you today i'm also pleased
that we have two members of the School
of Journalism here today showing our
data chops you wouldn't have thought
about it from journalist we made it so
what I thought I would do is I written
up some reactions to the first two
presentations and I thought I would give
you a little context for those reactions
once the slides come up do you want me
to try re
and thank you jen for the dongle room
full of Max one dongle yeah you are
there we are
yeah it's good oh
alright so the first slide is simply
that I'm from the brown Institute for
those of you haven't heard of it it's it
was a Institute created about just over
a year ago 30 million 30 million dollar
gift from Helen Gurley Brown pictured
here with her husband David the
Institute exists to co-evolved
technology and storytelling and is
housed in the School of Journalism in
the idea of or looking at the the idea
of integrate and analyze I thought I
would present very briefly to works that
I've been involved in I'm in the School
of Journalism but i'm i'm just going to
come out out myself publicly i am not a
journalist I'm a statistician by
training and I'm learning very quickly
what it means to be a journalist so the
first project that I'll talk about it
actually deals quite nicely with metrics
this is a project with jer thorp who was
at the time the data artist in residence
in new york times and i was having a
sabbatical there the project is called
cascade and it was the subject of my
sabbatical was to figure out how people
were sharing New York Times links across
Twitter in terms of integrate we had
data from a variety of sources we had
people's browsing behavior so we can
watch you browsing the New York Times
site we had some data from bit ly so we
watched you take a long URL and shorten
it bit ly the URL shortener also is nyti
ms so we saw most of the people who are
shortening things on New York Times we
saw that that shortened link appear on
Twitter tweets and retweets saw people
clicking on those tweets coming back to
the site and browsing so we had a full
if you will cascade of events that were
kicked off by your activity of browsing
the site in the morning and tweeting
about it our goal was to create a
visualization here it is this is a
particular story time is running along
the x-axis every pink dot you see is a
tweet every yellow dot is someone coming
back to the site that is clicking on
that tweet all of these tweets are about
a particular story called but will it
make you happy this story was about
should you be buying things
experiences so you see people sort of
clicking the height of the display has
to do with the how far away you are so
as you retweet other people you get
farther and farther away at the very top
there's a histogram that's counting the
number of tweets and then at some moment
things explode so you see that like
large spike happening in the histogram
you can climb up the backbone of the
Cascade and see that this that this
chain became with a started with the
tweet from Valdis Krebs you can follow
along until you find that that huge
spike of activity came when the zappos
CEO tweeted about the about the story
which is interesting because Zappos is
the company that sells you shoes in
various things so to be tweeting about
an article of this sort says something
about how corporations are the presents
that they're managing on Twitter what I
wanted to show you here though the
Twitter context is important i suppose
resonates given the the impact that we
were talking about before but this is a
non-standard data visualization this is
a piece of code that is acting as an
exploratory tool you can get this you
can get a display like this for any of
the of the New York Times stories for
any of the Cascades around their stories
and you can start to drill in you can
look at the networks that were activated
when people tweet about certain topics
but it's an exploratory tool it's not
giving you hard answers it's living
somewhere between that hard edge
statistics and and and an out and
informal analysis here are some use the
second project I wanted to mention is is
like as with this exploratory example
meant to loosen up but we might mean by
analyze I've had the good fortune of
working on a number of public artworks
which go statistician go you know media
art so the piece I'm going to describe
here it sort of brings analyze to add in
a different context this is a site
specific piece it's at the public
theater in here in the city it's
actually this thing that hovers above
the bar
having many of you been to the public to
see expected in this crowd to be at
least a few of you so it's called the
Shakespeare machine there are 37 blades
why Shakespeare 37 right this is the
number of plays in the folio and so one
blade for each play each blade displays
a separate a separate data from or text
from a separate play here's the piece in
action this uh if it starts because this
is the inevitable show your work scene
where we just show all the texts from
all the plays we then have a program
again in the integrate and analyze
analysis here is looking at four
different rhetorical structures that
Shakespeare used this for example is
looking at all the hyphenates that were
used in each of the plays so again each
blade is showing the hyphen it's from a
separate play we also benefiting from
the hard work from the digital
humanities leverage the monk database
and went on up a analysis if you will
that what we were referring to as an
afro mining looking for the rhetorical
structures that Shakespeare used and
highlighting those so here for example
we're looking for patterns like a
liberal and free idle and I can't read
it from here so we're looking to
automatically extract those rhetorical
structures pattern in part of speech
usage in specific word usage or
informatics is this garden imagery is
this water imagery again we're basically
making use of the byproducts of digital
humanities work that to a statistician I
can think of six parts of speech but
these folks gave us a hundred and fifty
different parts of speech which I'm a
little intimidated by but if you start
to extract those parts of speech you
find that across all the plays there
were 30 404 occurrences of a
terminar an adjective in a singular noun
you break those apart and it's a lovely
list because it's really hard to kill
Shakespeare even when you treat him as
data so what I wanted to say with those
examples is that is that that well
oftentimes my discipline statistics will
push forward data as a very technical
object data also exists to support a
variety of creative practices and that
the work that's being done in that area
can give back to statistics can give
back to data science in a sense data
science or a larger understanding of
data should integrate practices coming
from a variety of places which also
comes back to the the idea of a
statistician sitting in a school of
journalism I'm teaching a class this
semester called journalistic computing
and one of the thing I'm finding is that
when journalists are in control of the
technology when you start to train and
question journalists about the tools
that they would like to see or the ways
in which they perform that the
fundamentally journalistically inflected
technology will look different than
computer science created technology
right there a different set of values
transparency and so on that come with
journalism that will change and shape
the way technology data technologies
look right and so in part the call to
data science the call to the data
sciences institute is to integrate those
practices is to integrate the different
ways that different disciplines now are
making use of data bring that to a kind
of larger broader understanding I guess
I'll finish with the I just the basic
idea that you all you all know that that
data at their core whether it's
measuring impact or looking at
sociological phenomenon data at their
core are fundamentally human that
without human effort Hugh mat without
observation without memory we don't have
data and that the analysis of that data
should be just as human my poor field
statistics often is charged with sucking
the life out of the kind of analysis and
creativity that people might have with
data and I'd like to see ways to bring
it back again people stop there
so we now have time for discussion and
as moderator I think I'll kick it off
with a question to the panelists myself
since I'm from computer science well my
question probably goes a bit more to the
other two than to you mark but i'm i'm
curious how much of the kind of analysis
that you're doing can be done
automatically and where we look for for
pulling things together from different
disciplines where you might look to
computer scientists for things which you
would like to be able to do but perhaps
are not able to yet so i'm wondering in
particular about the analysis of
unstructured data like text video or
speech so Susan you you talked about the
analysis of the Medicare data and needed
to be able to look at the columns and
you still then had a table or a chart
and I'm wondering whether if you're able
to look in at some kind of text if that
could tell you more and for heather i
would ask in your analysis of citations
whether if you're able to look in at the
text and to see what people are saying
about the citations if that could help
you more in terms of coming up with
impact so maybe Susan thank you yeah so
I also take this as an opportunity to do
a small plug which is that also at the
journalism school and part of something
called the towel center for digital
journalism which among other things
overseas a dual degree program in
computer science and journalism so I
think in journalism I mean our field is
actually turning very much towards
computer science and in it least insofar
as you say to sort of we're very
pragmatic people right so we want to
a problem and you know text analysis i
think is one of those things where as
journalists there there are a lot of
things that we can do and i have a bit
of a background in computer science but
when we start to talk about text
processing natural language processing
that's where the sort of lower lower
level tools are really not are not as
successful and i think that there is an
enormous amount of capacity I mean it's
both in the journalism and frankly in
the commercial world for there's
enormous appetite for that kind of
analysis because ultimately it's not
just you know I mean I think something
like WikiLeaks is a perfect example and
and what we tend to do often or where
the our field is moving is both in
reaching out to computer science and
reaching out to our audience and I think
this is actually where you know some of
what Heather was talking about really
sort of resonates is this idea that we
can look at what people are doing with
our data and and saying about it her
example brought to mind the fact that
the Guardian data blog that I mentioned
was one of the first outlets to
aggressively publish the data behind
their articles and and that's one of the
ways they generated such an active
readership and they also very often put
out calls to their readers to do
analysis and visualization and say what
do you make of this I know they're
running a contest right now so I think
there's a two-pronged approach the
challenge is that again as journalists
we don't have the expertise all the time
and so it's it's it's hard to engage the
computer science when you don't know
what you're looking for but at the same
time and so for us the the the flip side
of that is engaging our readers who very
often have expertise that we don't have
Heather do you work the comments yeah
I'd love to comment um it's a great
point so I think in terms of text
analysis which maybe I'll just answer it
from that perspective there is a lot
that we could learn from computer
science and and the computer science
could help with in fact it's a
frustration for me a huge frustration
that um that
computer scientists right now often use
movie reviews and they use Twitter
archives and things for doing their text
analysis because our research papers
aren't available for them to easily mine
and this means that the every every text
mining problem is most easily customized
it works best when it's customized to
the type of content and we're behind on
doing text analysis on the type of
writing that scientific papers and other
research is written in because that text
isn't available um so so some of the
things that computer scientists right
now doing using the type of queries that
we can easily do which is binary queries
on text that is an open access um we we
can't even find out when when some when
there's a reference to a data set in
text if it's a reference in the context
of the data having been produced by the
authors of that paper and they're saying
we're headed where it has been deposited
or is it in the context of someone using
that data and and it's about their paper
believe me I would have tried to do this
and it is really and others have tried
to and it is not easy and that is the
most simple of tasks right now it's it's
unstructured data but it's important to
go beyond that to write and understand
when when it's been reused was it out
the only data set that was reused in
that paper was it an important part of
the UM papers conclusions was it just
one of many things are they critiquing
it um there isn't there are efforts
going on to try to structure that data
using the site o ontology for citations
for example but the adoption there's
going to be tricky and having a real NLP
people focusing on those problems would
be key and I'll just segue i'll just
mention a little that similarly mentions
in blogs and mentions in comments and
understanding whether those are our
critiques or additions or whatever
that's all key to the impact story for
sure okay
Thanks yeah i would just a plug for my
own research because we are doing
natural language analysis of journal
articles under a project funded by I
ARPA and so we are looking at some of
these issues it would be you know great
to get together with you and talk about
how we could combine our talents but I I
would second your plug all our data we
can only access on the government's
computers because the with the the
publishers have not made it open access
so we have to do all our computation not
on our local computers precisely because
of the copyright issues so if I get you
on that if I could just jump in to say
that's not an excuse for any of us right
I think you would agree with this we
need to keep asking and we need to keep
demanding both you never know what
you're going to get and people won't
give it to unless they recognize that
there's a real need so we all need to
ask and I think that's part of our
responsibility all right so let's open
up to the audience yeah Oh over here in
the front
I would recommend that you do your
analysis on open access articles this
way you're ignoring the publishers works
that they're not enabling you to use and
you're rewarding the open access
articles we we do on open access as well
but there's an order of magnitude larger
number of articles that we have
available to us that are not open access
so we like to work at scale awesome all
right other questions yeah I Peter
marine rust I just like to second all of
that that the lack of access to material
is not just the stuff you're going to
mine it is the whole infrastructure of
natural language processing it's the
dictionaries the ontology the gold
standards the tests everything you know
this is required for high quality text
mining and you have to have access to
this and it simply held us back by years
it's as simple as that okay other
comments we have over on the side so
this is a general question about
integration so and how would you
describe in simple words what do you
think are the most challenging barriers
for you in integrating your ether genius
data so well it's more about the
structure it's more about the semantics
I don't know whatever you think i would
say in our field for journalism one of
the biggest problems we have is just
this the siloed coding so I mean the
coding as in the end coding of the same
entity with different references and the
inability the lack of knowledge about
how to correlate those you know followed
by just sort of format differences right
so that that's a big that's a big issue
for us
i guess i would i would say that a big
issue also is is knowing what the
integrations actually done when you
zipper two things together certain
amount of stuff falls on the floor like
have you you know have you what have you
left behind what you know often when
you're doing this on large data sets
it's a little bit difficult to know
what's there and what's been what you
know what sort of systemic things might
have happened in the process so
trainings in statistics anyway training
students to to start to ask those
questions right to interrogate that
process a little bit more to open it up
a little bit more and then also to
document right to document because those
steps are often steps that are you know
maybe it happens in a spreadsheet
somewhere maybe it happens in a bit and
you know how do you document that how do
you keep track of those steps so someone
later can build on it I'd say data that
isn't exposed from our tools and data
that isn't open other comments I have a
question for Heather but others are
welcome too if you like to respond so
one of our colleagues pointed out that
tenure is a very strong motivator in our
community and during your presentation
it occurred to me that what would appear
in a tenure promotion packet of the
future would be an interesting thing to
wireframe could you describe some of the
components I may think you had a slide
eventually that had some features on it
but what what would you expect to see
there for sure and I'll in fact take the
opportunity to plug a publication that I
had in January in nature which is not an
open-access publication I will admit it
was a comment so please shoot me now so
um so I think that the great thing about
alternative products and including those
in tenure and in grant applications
which are key times and hiring which are
key times when people are making the
case that they've had impact a great
thing about alternative products like
data sets is
they don't have an established impact
thing to rely on like journal impact
factor and they they can't easily get
one and that means that the impact
metrics I think will be data set level
they won't be about the container they
won't be about where it's hosted they'll
be about the impact that that particular
item has made and so I think that um
that those metrics should be sometimes
quantitative with numbers and context
and context that's relevant for that
particular situation whether it's
discipline specific or data type
specific or and I think they should also
often be qualitative so so the
quantitative numbers are often a place
to drill in and start to see um who's
done what with it and and and find the
deeper story and so there should often
be a sentence or two like that I think
some funders are starting to suggest
having sentences like that and that
accompany grants yeah if I can add to
that the interesting thing so the the
idea that a data set or in my field code
would be counted in a in a 10-year case
it's a little bit difficult because you
end up I think that the tenure
committees don't quite know what to
don't recognize the amount of work that
goes into a piece of code the amount of
work that goes into data so the
publication obviously that's the
priority right and then the code and the
amount of time and the community gives
it sort of hard to evaluate those and so
I think maybe the the wireframe of the
future has to have something that would
help a tenure committee you know expose
or give an appropriate amount of an
appropriate amount of weight to that the
other thing is that that you almost
don't want a wireframe it too closely
because I feel like telling a story from
the data like using the methods that are
using the metrics that Heather's
recommending force the tenure committee
to do a little work or I forced them to
tell an appropriate story in an
appropriate way and to capture the
contribution that this that the person
that they're evaluating has brought up
don't the reason I think we reduce to
citation counts or whatever is that it's
easy
right not not just that that's the only
measure available but that it's easy
actually have a separate question but
just on this last point I'd want to
mention that here at the Earth Institute
at Columbia we've developed a set of
practice criteria for promotion which
are already being used in promotion
cases which takes into account of
alternative outputs and their evaluation
and matting can include data can include
having you know helping to save lives in
millennium villages around the world and
so forth so there are some changes it
was approved by the Provost of the
University so it's it's is legitimized
within our structure and it's someone
related Heather you had a point in your
slides which was about impact on policy
makers and practitioners but I didn't
really see much you know discussion of
how you would develop quantitative
metrics I mean I think we had a examples
from how the policy people look at data
anecdotally in the journalism world but
what would you see is quantitative
metrics for impacts on policy on
decisions on use of data in the field to
you know have beneficial the using the
benefits of scientific data that's a
fantastic question and I think we're not
remotely there yet right that the tools
can't do that yet but of the way some of
the first steps I think we could do to
get there is to policymakers if they're
using the data they're using it in some
tool right there bookmarking they're
downloading it potentially they're
logged in potentially they've identified
themselves as a policymaker potentially
they're bookmarking it um somewhere like
mendeley where maybe they've identified
themselves as a policymaker potentially
they're using it in one dataone our
right to analyze it and perhaps there
they've identified themselves as
an affiliation that suggests seeeeee
their intended use cases and then I
think ideally we get I think this is
hard but ideally we get people in their
outputs to do a better job of
referencing things so I think policies
don't usually show the data that went
into them but but potentially there's
ways that we can move towards systems
that do that better some of the very
earliest places where I'm guessing this
will go I think I'll metrics calm is
already doing this a little bit in
tweets is to mine those bio profiles to
see if for example if someone's a
scientist or if someone is a health
clinician and then see if they're
talking about papers or data sets on
Twitter that's one of the very early
stages but i think that's that's one way
to go looking in patents is a
traditional way to try to start to work
on economic impact and things like that
yeah I have a comment on this
self-identification so we register about
20,000 users each year on nanohub and if
you look at the stats there's maybe ten
percent of the people that actually tell
you who they are what they really want
to do because many people don't know
what they're going to do so you have to
almost look at their behavior to figure
out what they do eventually and we know
for example five percent of the users
say they're from industry if we survey
them quietly it's ten percent eight
percent of the authors are from industry
so so there's a lot of misconception
when people sign up so sign up through
Facebook and then looking at their
patterns of what they might really be is
much more impactful and assuming that
you're getting the right answer upfront
so and it's not even L spirited it's
they don't necessarily know what they're
going to use it for people tone on top
is cool go there try it out and they
don't know what they're going to say or
do right so it's actually a process to
get the data get an understanding ok I
think we're at the end of our time so
let's thank the panel is swimwear time
you